Speaker 1: Let's go with with some caution and
trepidation. To Oz from Kentucky. Oz, last time
we heard from you. You weren't doing great.
And I'm hoping that you're doing better today.
Speaker 4: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'm doing a lot better.
David. I haven't talked to you in a
couple of years. Actually, I don't think.
Speaker 1: Has it been that long?
Speaker 4: I don't think I've
talked to you even since my
grandma passed away from COVID and like, 2000.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, I'm sorry to hear that.
Speaker 4: Like I ran for Congress.
Did I tell you that? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we spoke around the time of that.
Speaker 4: Oh, okay. I don't I didn't I didn't
remember telling you that I ended up I ran
as an independent against Thomas Massie,
and I ended up getting 10,000 and. I think
10,000 over 10,000 votes. I got 4% of the vote.
Speaker 1: Is that right?
Speaker 4: So I got the most
votes for an independent in my district's
history, and I think I'm the only open
socialist that's ever ran in this district.
Speaker 1: So I see it, right? Is it okay to
say your name? I mean, you're a public person.
Can I say your name? Yeah. So I'm seeing here
the results. Ethan Osborne, you got 10,000 votes.
4% of the vote. That's fantastic. That's good. I
mean, Massie is sort of like a big time incumbent.
Speaker 4: Yeah. He's he's won every election
since 2012 when he took office. Yeah. Which
is pretty. He's one of the fascinating.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE. As
far as his politics, he's so.
Speaker 1: What's more, what's next now?
Speaker 4: Um, I don't know, I. I think
I'm just going to help other people. I have a
friend who's running as a Democrat for state rep,
and I'm just. I think I'm just going to
help other people's campaigns next cycle,
and I'm just more focused on organizing and,
you know, direct action and activism for now.
Speaker 1: That's fantastic. And listen, as
you're doing it in a place where it's so needed,
which is Kentucky, I get calls all the time from
people who are basically ready to abandon their
red states because they need to for their
family or for whatever reason. And I respect
that. But I also greatly respect what you're
doing, which is you're staying in the place
and you're doing what you can to improve it.
Speaker 4: Yeah. It's and it's tough to I mean,
we've got some real problems with fascism
here that's getting worse in this area.
And I'm I have I don't have much choice
because, you know, I have shared custody
of my son until I turn ah, until he turns
18. So. Right. And so I'm here for him. Wow.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I hope that you will
rack up some improvements. Be they modest or
big in in your area, This is the critical
thing. How can we improve the place where
we live? And that's what you're trying to do?
Speaker 4: Absolutely. Yeah. I think everyone
in mutual aid networks right now as much
as possible, because I think the left needs
to start prepping. I think that's imperative.
Speaker 1: Yeah. There is a left prep movement,
by the way. That's an interesting thing you bring
up. Listen, Oz, it's so great to hear you sounding
so good. I really appreciate you calling in.
Speaker 4: Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Oz from Kentucky,
4%. I mean, listen, it's nothing to sneeze at.
Nothing to sneeze at whatsoever. And so, so
great to hear from Oz. All right, everybody,
we will take calls again, just not today.
Okay. Just not today. I'm out of time and
I will speak to everybody very soon. Quick break.
And then right back as the Friday show continues.